hello my name is Eric Chow and I direct
the UCSF centered for viens technology
today I'm gonna give you a training
video on how to ask operate the Agilent
file analyzer this is the system used to
QC nucleic acids see it go into
next-generation sequencing library preps
as well as checking the quality of your
final libraries for sequencing this is
the bio analyzer essentially the system
works by a capillary electrophoresis but
instead of running samples through a
long thin capillary all the separation
occurs on these microfluidic chips over
here so I'm going to open up this chip
and show you some more details of this
chip the chip is actually made out of
glass and there are several wells on the
chip and this glass chip is embedded
into a plastic frame and on the back of
this chip you'll be able to see a whole
bunch of different channels and this is
where all the different samples will run
and get separated and then get detected
this chip once it's prepared will go
into this bioanalyzer instruments and
this instrument has a location to hold
the chip as well as an optical detector
at the bottom to detect the passing
declic acids and an electrode array on
top and this electrode array on top is
what causes the different samples that
pass through the chip and migrate
towards actor and protector so we
haven't done anything prepare the chip
yet and we'll go through that next so
with all the different kits for the
bioanalyzer you can analyze both RNA and
DNA they come with a handy user guide
that will essentially be following today
and in this user guide there are
sections where it tells you to prepare a
gel dye mixture this is something you
have to do ahead of time and it takes
about 30 minutes so this is something
we've done before before we shot this
video but all the reasons for the kits
come in a small box like this that's
kept in the cold room and they all come
with a pack of chips that are at room
temperature and so once you open up this
box and today we're gonna be going over
the DNA height sensitivity kits you'll
see a set of reagents in here and the
reagents that you'll need to prepare the
gel dye mixture ahead of time
our a dye the gel and a spin filter and
what you'll do a head of time is take a
certain amount of the dye added through
the gel and vortex it and then you'll
place this gel dye mixture into this
Eppendorf tube that has a spin filter in
there and you'll centrifuge this for
about 30 minutes
this will cause that gel dye to form a
nice even suspension and when you're
done you'll throw away the filter it and
keep the gel dye in this Eppendorf tube
at 4 degrees and you'll be able to use
this gel die mixture several times for
for several runs across many chips so
what I have here is the tube of gel dye
that we've already prepared and this is
what we'll be using today but before we
start preparing the chip I'm gonna
demonstrate to you how to run the
software the software that runs the bio
analyzer is the 20100 expert software
when you open up the software it will
automatically connect to the biome
analyzer instruments and on the left are
a set of tabs that icons that you can
use to navigate to different areas of
the software to set up the run you want
to make sure you click on the instrument
icon and on the instrument icon again
you'll see a picture of the bio analyzer
and the first thing you want to do is
select the assay that you're running
again the violent eliezer you can
analyze both DNA and RNA and if you're
selecting DNA you want to select the
proper chip and today we're running the
high sensitivity chip for RNA there are
two different types of kits there are
these nano and pico kits as well as a
small RNA kit if you want to run small
RNA essays but what's important about
the Nano and Pico kids to be analyzing
RNA and one that gets a Rin number this
is an RNA integrity number you have to
make sure that you select the total RNA
options and this will cause the software
to calculate a Rin number if you select
the mrna options you won't get a Rin
number for your RNA so against running
DNA high sensitivity will go to double
standard DNA and select high sensitivity
next you have an option to select where
your data get saved - you can save into
a default folder or a custom folder that
you select after that let the system
know how many samples you'll be running
on the high-sensitivity DNA chip you can
run up to 11 samples today will only be
running two samples and at the bottom
you can give names of your different
samples and you can label them down here
and so we'll just use sample a and
sample B so now we're going to setup the
instrument and the chips to run your
samples again this is the biome analyzer
and this head opens up and down to get
the electrodes into a chip if you need
to remove your electrode simply flip
down a tab sits over here all the way to
the bottom this will push out the
electrode array by a little bit and once
it's out you can slide it back and if
you need to store this electrode array
store it upside down so that these
electrodes don't get damaged by bumping
up against surfaces to put the electrode
back into the system simply slide it
back down and allow to go down on its
own don't force it in once it's dropped
to the lowest position lift the lever up
and this will pull the electrode array
in the next thing we're going to do is
wash the system to wash the system you
want to use 350 microliters of nucleus
free water and place it into a wash chip
you can use any well of the wash ship
because all the wells are connected by a
reservoir to wash
simply place the wash ship on the chip
holder and close the system and let it
sit for about thirty seconds to one
minute all this does is wash off any
salts and debris that might be on the
surface of those electrodes once the
wash is done go ahead and remove the
chip and you can just dump out the water
into the trash and save the chip for
future runs now we'll prepare our chip
I've already opened this up from the
plastic packaging and we'll place this
into the priming station the chip sits
down in here and doesn't really move and
on the priming station and supporting
the note that this is made of a plunger
and there is a holder to hold the
plunger at different positions and
depending on which chip and si you use
you'll need to make sure that you set
the plunger to the proper setting so
there's a top middle and bottom setting
for the high sensitivity DNA chips we'll
have to use this lower setting and so
you just move the silver handle down
until you get it to this lower location
and make sure it catches into the hold
so now this is set at the load position
and we're ready to start adding our
reagents the first reagent we'll be
using is the gel dye mix that we
prepared ahead of time this has had the
dye added to the gel and spun through a
filter already what we'll do first is
add nine microliters of the gel dye
mixture to the gel position that's
marked with a dark circle on your chip
and this is going to be the second from
the bottom when you add reagents to
these chips you want to make sure that
you touch the bottom of the chip you
don't have to worry about marring them
because they're made out of glass so
they're much harder than your pipette
chips
the other thing you want to make sure
that you don't do is expel a bubble at
the bottom of the chip because that's
where those capillaries and channels are
if you have an air bubble down there
it's gonna disrupt the flow of currents
the next step is to bring the syringe up
to the 1 mil mark and then snap the lid
shut until you hear a click next gently
in steadily push the plunger all the way
down until it touches the hold and you
want to set a timer for 1 minutes what's
happening right now is the pressure in
the syringe is forcing that gel dye
mixture through a capillary inside of
the chip and this is forming that
separation channel that all the samples
will go through so both the pressure and
timing are important for the different
chips so make sure you consult your user
guide if you're running something else
besides the high sensitivity DNA chip so
while this is running we have about
another 30 seconds one thing you can use
to check your chips afterwards is you
want to make sure that you don't see any
of the channels after pressurization
because now they've all been filled with
liquids before we do this step if you
take a look at your chip on the back you
can actually see all the channels if you
hold it up to the light because of the
glass air interfaces that are present
but after priming you shouldn't see
those anymore because they should all be
fluid build a minute is up and we'll
just release the plunger what you want
to see is the plunger going up past the
half mil mark within a couple of seconds
and this is in case that no pressure has
leaked out of the system and so now you
just slowly bring the plunger back up to
the 1 mil mark and then release the
plunger from the chip next we'll add
another 9 microliters of the gel dye
mixture to the other 3 gel positions on
the chip these are the other three wells
on the right side of the chip you can
use the same pipette tip for all of
these and again just remember not to
expel any air bubbles towards the bottom
of the
the bottom of the wells
next we're gonna add 5 microliters of a
marker solution to each of the sample
wells and the latter Wells these are the
twelve wells to the left of the chip so
we don't add these to the gel wells that
we've added material to already and you
can use the same pipette for all of
these as well and this just contains an
upper and lower marker that can be used
as reference standards to compare your
sample to the latter so even if you're
only running one or two samples or not a
full 11 samples you still have to add
marker to all of the lanes or to all of
the wells
and the next step will add one
microliter of the ladder to the ladder
well and this is marked on the chip
now we can add your samples and again
there are references to the well number
that correspond to the sample numbers on
the chip
I only have two samples so I'm now done
but you can proceed with up to 11
samples on this chip the next step is to
mix the contents of the of the marker
and the the samples or the ladder in the
chip and to do this we use a special for
texture that comes with every
bioanalyzer so just make sure it's set
to the proper set point and then allow
to mix and make sure you set a timer so
that you have you know when to stop and
again to get the time for the different
assays just consult your user guide
alright times up now the chip is
prepared and ready to run what we want
to do is go ahead and place this into
the bio analyzer system close the lid
and then once the system detects a chip
you'll be able to click on the start
button to begin the run a run of a full
chip will generally take about 45
minutes and it's good idea to stick
around for a few minutes till you see
the the latter run just to make sure the
run has started okay before you take off
now our second and last sample is
running what you see here is a rock
trait from the bio analyzer and this is
analyzing fluorescence that's being
detected as sample passes through the
capillary on the low end we have the
lower marker and over here we have the
upper marker these are used as internal
references and paired the sample to the
ladder that was run first and in the
middle here is our library this is a
high concentration sample is roughly at
around 25 nano molar and so this is why
this smear is so large you'll notice
that the marker Peaks are pretty sharp
because they're a defined size and
libraries tend to have a spread to them
because they come in a variety of sizes
they're not one specific base pair
length and so now the run is finishing
and I'll show you how to analyze and
export the data so now that screen is
disappeared the run is done to access
our data we come back over to the
left-hand side and click on the data
icon
if you have several runs from beforehand
you'll see the other chips here the
newest one will be at the bottom which
is our sample and if we click on that
chip we'll get some details about the
the chip the assay properties and then
if you want to take a look the raw
traces you click on the electropherogram
and this will show you the trace for
either at one sample at a time so this
is our first sample and this was our
second sample or you can look at all
samples at once
and here sample a and sample B and down
here is the ladder and so if we click on
the ladder it has a series of Peaks that
are present in that ladder sample and
the ladder also contained the marker
that we added the 5 microliters agents
and those are this 35 base pair and
roughly 10 KB base pair fragments that
are present in all samples and so the
ladder is used as a reference because we
know the sizes and we correlate it with
the time that it takes for those samples
to come through the chip and we have
these internal references that we'll use
compared each of the samples so now if
you click on sample a it'll also have
that 35 and 10 KB marker that are used
to generate the the sizing of these
samples so down here on the
electropherogram there are a couple of
things you can do you can set something
called a reagent table and for next-gen
sequencing libraries you typically set
these around 200 base pairs up to 1 KB
and that's displayed here and what this
will do is it will analyze only the
material that shows up within this range
and this will give you a rough
concentration in pika moles so this is a
little over 4000 pika mobile molar
concentration or roughly 4 nano molars
it'll also give you an average size
which is useful for some downstream
queue seeing steps and so this library
has an average size of 320 base pairs
our other high concentration sample
again is also being analyzed in the
Spear region and what you can see is
that this is a much higher concentration
library this is measuring it at roughly
17 animal ur and the average size is 490
base-pairs sometimes the bioanalyzer
won't detect your marker Peaks correctly
and you'll see a red flag or red mark
down here in the simulated gel image
this is something that's easy to correct
by going to the peak table tab over here
so for instance on this sample B we have
this minor peak that showed up sometimes
this minor peak might get misidentified
as a marker and on this peak table what
you can do is you can highlight over
these Peaks and once see a bull's-eye up
here you can right-click and manually
set them as the lower or upper marker
and so for instance if I wanted to call
this 29 base pair peak by 35 base pair
standard or internal reference I can
right click on it and manually set the
lower marker and this will recalculate
the size of everything so now you can
see that the software is now call this
my 35 base pair peak and it's calling
this marker of 46 base pair peak so this
isn't what I actually want so I'll go
ahead and change it back and hover over
my actual lower marker see the bullseye
right click and set lower marker so once
your data looks like it's all been set
and is all the peaks have been properly
called you can export this as a PDF by
clicking the printer buttons on the
toolbar and so sometimes they'll ask you
if you want to save any changes and so I
said yes I want to save those changes
that I made a window will show up and
it'll give you options of what type of
items to select we just leave this as
the default you can tell it to print all
wells or just the wells that you have
samples and for us you only had two
samples and then you have options to
export this as a PDF or an HTML HTML
file and to select the directory that
you want to export this to so I'm just
going to save it to the desktop to make
it easier to find and you have options
to put four sheets per page or one sheet
per page so I'll go ahead and save this
and if we go to the desktop we should be
able to see our PDF file and that should
be here so if you double-click on this
you'll see a summary report on the first
page and as you scroll down you'll see
the latter over here and you want to see
nice tight sharp bands or Peaks on the
ladder and then you'll see the samples
and these will include some extra
information down at the bottom and so
most people will want to save the PDF
because this is file they can open on
their own computers you can't open the
actual bioanalyzer RAW files these xad
files because it requires the
proprietary software so you definitely
want to export and save that PDF and
generally this PDF is what you would
send off to your sequencing facility if
you're getting sample sequences so now
that the run is completed the last thing
we have to do is wash the system so
first thing you want to do is pull out
the old chip set it aside you can throw
it away it's unusable right now and then
take another wash chip and fill it again
with 350 microliters of nucleus free
water
and then place a chip in the system and
close a lid and let it sit for about
thirty seconds to one minute and it's
really important that you this
afterwards because we want to clean the
electrodes in any gel and salts that are
gonna be on the electrodes from running
the chip it's not good to leave a chip
in there long-term because those things
can dry on those electrodes and cause
problems for the next user the other
point is that it's really important that
you remove the wash chip if you leave it
in there the water will start to
evaporate and cost condensation inside
an electrode array so there are a lot of
electronics up above that we don't want
to get moisture on so now that 36 is up
we remove the wash ship we can get rid
of the water set it aside and then just
close the system and you're done thanks
for watching